[Musique]
bonsoir mardi 28 avril bienvenue dans
cette nouvelle édition spéciale sur tv
et pour commencer comme chaque soir le
point sur la propagation du coït 19 dans
les yvelines hier lundi 4 108 décès a
été recensé dans le département soit 7
de plus en 24 heures le nombre
d'hospitalisations lui a reculé ce lundi
826 passion étaient concernés sur le
territoire 115 toujours placé en
réanimation
enfin 1337 le nombre de patients
désormais guéri du collier de 19 dans
les yvelines
43e jours de confinement et sa prise de
parole était attendu à moins de deux
semaines de la date du 11 mai edouard
philippe s'est exprimé cet après midi
devant les députés à l'assemblée
nationale le premier ministre a détaillé
le plan des confinement du gouvernement
à retenir principalement des compliments
qui se fera par territoire avec l'appui
des collectivités territoriales à partir
du 11 mai où tous les français devraient
pouvoir accéder à un masque grand public
réouverture de tous les commerces à
l'exception des cafés et restaurants une
décision sera prise fin mai aps objectif
de 700 mille tests sérologiques par
semaine enfin la réouverture des crèches
écoles maternelle et primaire à partir
du 11 mai ou le masque ne sera pas
obligatoire pour les enfants il le sera
en revanche pour les élèves de 6e et 5e
qui reprendront le chemin de l'école à
partir du 18 mai et décision sur la
réouverture des lycées qui sera prise
elle fin mai c'est un discours attendu
mais pas forcément de mesures précises
annoncé regrette la sénatrice des
yvelines martha de six breaks
j'ai quelques doutes sur l'efficacité
d'un tel discours
dans un moment quand même qui est somme
toute graves et pour lequel nous
attendons des informations très
concrètes pour l'aspect territorial en
fait du déconfinement département par
département
il a fait référence à ce qui avait déjà
été annoncé par le président de la
république à savoir le binôme si je puis
dire préfet maire donc c'est quelque
chose qui va de toute façon dans le bon
sens mais y'a rien nouveau sur le volet
des masques obligatoire il a été clair
pour dire que pour les enfants ce
n'était pas appropriée il a évoqué pour
les collégiens dans le cas où certains
ne pourrait pas sans fournir il faudra
que on leur en fournit ce là où il me
manque mois des informations pour me
prononcer pleinement sur ces mesures là
c'est que qui les fournit
dans quelles conditions et à quel moment
et moi ce que je relève en réalité sur
l'ensemble d'ailleurs de ce qui a été
dit c'est que healy a énormément de
choses qui vont incombe est de plus en
plus aux communes
inquiétude également du côté des mères
grégory des restes y est élu à maurepas
il s'interroge sur les conditions de la
reprise dans les écoles notamment
il était temps parce que en annonce un
déconfinement à partir du 11 mai et que
pour les élus locaux pour qu'on puisse
organiser
il nous reste plus que sept jours ouvrés
à peu près donc les mesures qui ont été
annoncées sont évidemment les bienvenues
malgré tout il n'y a pas trop de
nouveautés sans l'aide des élus locaux
et sans les élus terran l'état ne peut
rien faire donc c'est à aussi l'état de
nous accompagner donc on a quand même
une
j'allais dire une petite bonne nouvelle
c'est qu'on aura au moins 50 % du coût
des masques que nous avons achetés pour
le grand public qui sera pris en charge
donc on attend les détails
après moi je reste quand même inquiet
sur la reprise de scolaires ans le 11
même si on se prépare déjà depuis
quelques jours quelques semaines en
interne c'est l'accueil des enfants les
flux les gestes barrière la formation du
personnel municipal les produits à
utiliser est ce qu'on sera en capacité
et aussi la responsabilité qui est la
mienne qui est celle des élus locaux qui
n'a pas été abordée enfin côté
professeur le port du masque obligatoire
pour les collégiens rassure en revanche
quelques réserves sont émises sur la
limitation des classes à 15 élèves des
conditions difficiles à tenir dans des
salles de classes parfois petit écouter
ses ânes on ne nous ont pas vraiment
surprise un déjà puisque bon sur le
terrain on voit déjà que les conditions
étaient compliquées à mettre en oeuvre
que ces deux reprises décalées pour les
hisser futur n'est pas très surprenante
il n'y a pas grand chose de nouveau qui
a été annoncé donc sur les quinze élèves
maximum par classe
bon c'est déjà un chic est évoquée
depuis très longtemps et qui sera
compliquée à mettre en oeuvre sur la le
port du masque à la fois à la fois des
personnels encadrants professeur gilles
technique et cetera c'est évidemment une
bonne chose c'est tout ce qu'on
demandait et le fait de rendre
obligatoire également pour les élèves du
collège alors on espère que quand la
reprise on lycée sera évoqué ce soir ce
sera également le cas c'est aussi
quelque chose qui est pour
essentielle mais encore une fois qui
avec ce décalage de la reprise qui sera
d'ailleurs différentes selon les
départements dans les évidences
effectivement là qu'on a un département
qui est très touché que on est beaucoup
des plans des transports et c'est que ça
sera semble plus compliqué dans notre
département
voilà pour ces annonces et réactions
avec un travail législatif qui a
désormais débuter
et nous vous parlions hier de cette
disparition le docteur jacques fribourg
médecin urgentiste qui a été emporté ce
week-end par le coronavirus à l'âge de
68 ans est lé hommage au fondateur des
urgences de l'hôpital privé de trappes
se multiplient
le maire de trappes justement dit
malandain a fait savoir à qui il a
souhaité donner le nom de jacques
fribourg à un espace public de la ville
une volonté en l'honneur de ses
compétences son humanisme et de son
engagement professionnel pour sauver des
vies dit l'élu dans un communiqué une
délibération sera proposé à ce sujet au
prochain conseil municipal et jacques
fribourg qui laisse bien sûr un grand
souvenir à l'hôpital privé de l'ouest
parisien à trappes où il a exercé une
grande partie de sa carrière
l établissement qui continue comme les
autres dans les yvelines sa lutte contre
le virus
hier une remise de masques et de
protection s'est déroulée sur place des
distributions assuré par la région ile
de france qui a importé 15 millions de
masques depuis la chine le reportage de
nicolas landry et de patrick jacques de
dixmude 800 masques de type ffp2 une
centaine de sur blues tout ce matériel
est remis à l'hôpital privé de l'ouest
parisien basée à trappes des équipements
nécessaires pour cet établissement pour
restructurer des stocks après une
période de tension
ceci va permettre notamment de donner à
notre personnel des masques que nous
avons déjà pour toutes les personnes qui
vont venir pour des consultations des
visiteurs pour ceux qui sont autorisés à
rentrer ceux qui ont des masques qui
sont issus qui protège surtout ceux qui
n'ont pas de masque on a une certaine
amélioration
on a un peu moins de patients kovy de
qu'au départ on sent qu'on
le pic diminue après on reste vigilant
parce qu'on a toujours tous les gestes
barrières et on est en zone de
confinement de toute façon sur le
territoire comme toute la france donc on
attend de voir un peu comment le
déconfinement va se passer et on reste
prudent moins de patients une
amélioration de la situation sanitaire
de son côté la région ile de france
continue de fournir des équipements en
fonction des besoins
chaque élu sur son territoire par la
région été mandaté pour prendre la tâche
des structures de santé donc j'ai eu le
directeur général kim a indiqué son type
de besoins plus précisément entre
chirurgicaux pas chirurgicaux et ffp2 et
puis ensuite la région a fait a prévu un
lot pour l'hôpital de trappes je suis
venu apporter aujourd'hui dans quelques
jours des masques ffp2 seront remis
aussi au centre qu'ovide 10,9 de la
ville de montigny le bretonneux et début
mai des masques cette fois-ci grand
public devrait être plus accessible pour
les français c'est une promesse d'
edouard philippe
en attendant vous pouvez en trouver du
mardi au samedi sur le marché notre dame
à versailles le fabricant en mousse
robert implanté en eure-et-loir vont
habituellement de la mousse sur mesure
sur ce marché avec la crise sanitaire il
s'est reconverti dans la fabrication de
masques en coton et a été sollicité par
la municipalité pour les vendre aux
versaillais est les propos recueillis
par aurélie ronze et patrick jacques de
dixmude le masque demande d'énormes donc
on a respecté la norme afnor de façon à
proposer un masque qui pose pas de
problème pour le pour les clients ce
qu'on préconise c'est de le laver à la
main
en fait de faire
à lavage au savon de marseille et
puis le rincer puis ensuite prendre la
bouilloire et faire chauffer de l'eau à
90 et laissé environ cinq minutes dans
le verset cette eau chaude sur le masque
ski le stérilise et ensuite le laisser
sécher au soleil
bon on a de la chance on a du soleil en
ce moment autrement il ya le et après
demain le fer à repasser donc savon de
marseille ou chaude très chaude plus le
fer à repasser les virus ils sont ils
sont pas la nôtre le marché notre dame
qui fonctionne partiellement depuis plus
d'une semaine maintenant grâce à des
stands disposés à l'extérieur des halles
sa réouverture totale n'a pas été
autorisé pour autant par le préfet des
yvelines elle a repris son activité
depuis aujourd'hui malgré la crise
sanitaire l'usiné renault de flins sur
seine vient de relancer progressivement
la production
seul un tiers des 1300 salariés ont
repris le chemin du travail aujourd'hui
pour respecter la distanciation social
est le passage par un sas pour une prise
de température et une distribution de
gel hydro alcoolique est désormais
obligatoire pour accéder au site de 2
137 hectares est des mesures jugées pour
autant insuffisantes pour les syndicats
sur place où sera produite une centaine
de voitures par jour dans le nord des
yvelines toujours à mantes la ville plus
précisément le centre d'études et
d'initiatives musulmane des yvelines
propose à 300 familles dans le besoin
des colis de denrées alimentaires depuis
le début de cette crise sanitaire de
plus en plus de personnes font appel à
l'association pour répondre aux demandes
leucémie a renforcé son équipe de
bénévoles
patrick jacq de dissuader mathilde demi
hébergement d'urgence maraude avec
distribution de repas chauds remise de
colis alimentaires
le centre d'études et d'initiatives
musulmane des yvelines offre toute
l'année aux familles les plus démunies
des vivres avec le confinement le nombre
de familles demandeuses a triplé en un
peu plus de 300 familles qui sont
ravitaillés
donc en ce moment on distribue plus de
6 tonnes par semaine voilà donc ça
correspond un peu plus de 1200 personnes
qui bénéficient de cette aide de colis
alimentaires donc très concrètement
entre les produits secs que nous
distribuons plus les produits frais que
nous récupérons auprès de nos
partenaires de la grande distribution
donc tout ce qui est légumes viande
voilà
fruits laitages chaque famille
bénéficient d'un colis hebdomadaires à
peu près d'une valeur de 50 euros
donc ce qui fait à peu près que nous
injectons dans le budget des ménages à
peu près de 100 euros par mois pour les
maraudes les repas chauds sont cuisinés
sur place dans les cuisines de
l'association les colis alimentaires
sont pesées préparer avant d'être
distribués aux familles les 50 bénévoles
se relaient toute la journée pour
travailler 7 jours sur 7 comme philippe
qui a rejoint l'équipe au début du
confinement au début de ma mission
j'étais surtout affecté à la collecte
dans les magasins régulièrement en fait
le réseau de collecte s'est agrandie
aussi bien en nombre de points de vente
de collecte que de distance donc là
encore ce matin j'étais avec mon
équipier au nabot en normandie
et puis progressivement j'ai un petit
peu touché à toutes les tâches de la
delà de l'association dont je fais aussi
de la maraude le samedi soir aussi dû
dix passages de marchandises aussi de la
préparation de colis avec des fiches à
remplir manuellement ce qui est très
long pour le président de la mosquée une
crainte persiste les grossistes mans peu
à peu de provisions et les deux nations
se font de plus en plus rares la matière
première c'est la vie d'andré
alimentaire donc ça c'est très difficile
en ce moment on arrive où déconfinement
mais bon je pense que la situation va
dire quand même un moment par exemple la
banque alimentaire
tout ce qui est laid le carton
alimentaire donc on commence plus tôt
arrivé à la fin de leur réserve la
semaine dernière pour vous dire
qu'habituellement on était approvisionné
quatre cinq palettes la semaine dernière
on en a eu qu'une voilà ça vous donne un
peu une idée de l'échelle de de la
baisse des provisions
donc ça nous inquiète sérieusement donc
du coup on essaie de faire des appels
aux dons pour qu'on puisse compenser par
l'achat auprès de grossistes de ces
quantités qui vont manquer les jours et
les semaines à venir
l'association basée sur mantes la ville
oeuvre dans un rayon allant jusqu aux
mureaux même si la demande est plus
forte pendant la crise alimentaire le
centre d'études et d'initiatives
musulmane des yvelines continuera ses
opérations deux frères au tour du monde
à vélo c'est l'aventuré delbrouck que
vous suivez sans doute sur tv 78 au gré
des épisodes nous avons également
proposé un reportage récemment sur leur
confinement au pérou laventure d'aib
roux qui a été mis en tout cas en pause
pour le moment en raison des mesures
sanitaires ils sont revenus en france
les deux frères taurin qui sont avec
nous cabinet et guillaume bonsoir
bonsoir vous avez donc dû revenir en
france
c'était jeudi dernier vous êtes revenu
jeudi dernier le 23 avril vous étiez en
confinement au pérou déjà le fait de
rentrer cette décision pourquoi l'avoir
prise
est-ce que c'était une décision
difficile à prendre oui très difficile à
prendre ce qu'on a initialement au début
du confinement au pérou on voulait
rester au pérou on pensait attendre
quelques semaines
mais au fil des semaines on a vu la
situation s'aggrave et puis entendre
différents présidents dans le monde
dire que cette situation allait durer
très longtemps deuxièmement le pérou a
fermé ses frontières le 22 avril
donc nous avant cette période on s'est
dit mais est-ce que c'est raisonnable de
rester aussi longtemps au pérou et
qu'est ce qu'on va faire pendant tout ce
temps si on doit rester très longtemps
donc en mettant d'un côté les pourrait
d'un côté les contres s'est dit que le
plus raisonnable pour pour nous pour
notre santé c'était de rentrer en france
et kevin double d'il et les frontières
du pérou était fermée du coup commence à
s'organiser le rapatriement comment vous
avez pu revenir en france
alors en fait c'est un peu particulier
c'est les frontières
l'espace aérien qui était fermée à
partir du 22 avril il faut savoir que
les frontières ont été fermées
mi mars qu'en gros début du confinement
au pérou j'en tire terrestres et les
frontières aériennes mais on va dire
plus touristique donc dû pousser
on a et on a eu en fait 37 des vols à
destination de paris mais avec assez
particulier on était plus à l'aéroport
international de lima on était à
l'aéroport militaire
donc on était carrément déposé sur le
tarmac et donc c'est les militaires qui
nous ont pris en charge les militaires
français et militaires péruviens et la
gendarmerie aussi français ça nous a
fait assez c'est assez intriguant de les
voir sur le territoire d'un péruvien
étrangers pour le coup après ça s'est
très très bien passé une organisation
assez assez incroyable même de la part
de l'ambassade de france au pérou c'est
hallucinant tout ce qui a été mis en
oeuvre pour on va dire on dit
rapatriement mais en soi c'est pas le
terme exact apparemment donc on a saisi
cette dernière opportunité de rentrer
dans des conditions vraiment vraiment
spectaculaire à paris pour ceux qui
n'ont pas vu le reportage sur votre
confinement pérou ça ressemble à quoi
d'être confiné au terrou il ya plusieurs
règles qui ont été mis en place assez
rapidement par le pérou la première
c'était un couvre-feu
donc à partir alors selon les régions
bien sûr mais en gros à partir de 18
heures on pouvait plus sortir jusqu'à 5
heures du matin le lendemain
pendant un moment il ya eu des sorties
que par genre donc certains jours était
réservé aux hommes et d'autres jours
pour pour les femmes
ensuite il ya eu des débats les magasins
ont beaucoup de magasins qui était fermé
des salles
c'était et en france c'était beaucoup de
petites règles qui se mettait en place
assez rapidement au pérou le port du
masque qui était obligatoire et
conseillait aussi de porter des gants
donc c'était difficile à trouver mais
c'est vrai que le but de semaine de
confinement avaient beaucoup qui avaient
des masques
alors papa lé bon masque c'est
c'était de la débrouille tout ça mais la
population sait s'adapter assez
rapidement confinement pérou et
maintenant c'est le confinement france
tv nous et voilà
du coup maintenant c'est confinement en
france donc l'un guillaume et dans les
yvelines tout proche de vous l'autre
donc moi je suis plutôt planqué en
bretagne dépaysement total pour le
courant ne passait de lima villes très
peuplées avec pas mal de à l'époque des
pollutions une bonne campagne française
ça fait quand même bien plaisir de
revoir tout ça même si le décalage est
pour le moment assez fort il n'ya pas
que le décalage horaire il ya plein de
choses qui reviennent ça c'est assez
particulier mais ont donc là on se met
comme en 14 m
apparemment c'est ce qu'il faut dire le
temps que on voit ça on constate bien
quand même on était dans un avion 300
personnes en contact 12 heures dans
l'avion donc on essaie d'enlever mes
symptômes dus du coup renault virus y en
avait et puis on va ressortir
tranquillement on l'espère tous deux le
11 mai date du monde va effectivement
qui sera le début du déconfinement et
tout ça alors cette aventure elle a duré
presque deux ans vous êtes passé par
l'europe l'afrique l'amérique du sud
pour pour terminer je parlais tout à
l'heure de pause vous nous confirmez
bien que c'est une pause l'idée c'est
aussi de repartir dès que les conditions
seront remplies tout à fait voler l'idée
initiale c'est de faire un tour du monde
à vélo
donc il est important pour nous d'aller
au bout donc on va attendre le temps
nécessaire et repartir dès que possible
je sais que c'est dur important a résumé
en quelques secondes mais qu'est ce que
vous en retenez en tout quatre ses deux
premières années quasiment une tour du
monde à vélo de petit tour du monde à
vélo du coup petit je ne sais pas quand
mais l'accueil le continent
effectivement mais en tout cas elle
voilà ce début de tour du monde qu'est
ce que vous obtenez je pense que me
concernant c'est il ya beaucoup changé
beaucoup d'éléments à retenir
il ya d'énormes rencontre qu'on a faits
qui nous ont qui nous ont vraiment ont
marqué pendant le voyage il ya aussi
l'aspect un peu plus négatifs qui est
puisqu'ils touchent à la pollution et
aux déchets qu'on retrouve dans la
nature et ça c'est un constat qu'on a
tous remarqué il ya la pollution partout
et qu'il est très très très important et
urgent de faire attention à notre petite
planète et c'est une aventure
extraordinaire et c'est sûr qu'on en a
aujourd'hui déjà on n'en revient pas
comme comme on était parti à l'origine
beaucoup de changements et beaucoup de
changements dans le voyage bon ben c'est
à vivre pour pour se rendre compte pour
que les gens qui se rendent compte que
c'est c'est une autre vie et c'est très
enrichissant
je vous vois acquiescé guillaume
peut-être des choses a ajouté vous êtes
totalement d'accord avec kevin williams
tout ce qui l'intéressé c'est exact on
pense qu'on est parti on pensait pas que
ça allait aussi fort aussi prenants il
ya toutes les toutes les cultures qu'on
a qu'on a aussi rencontré ses différents
centres doivent par exemple le nord de
l'afrique et puis l'amérique du sud qui
est totalement différente et qui nous
ont enrichi du coup on a hâte
on a deux boucles et tout ça et bien on
vous souhaite de repartir très vite
merci
kevin et guillaume tora d'avoir été avec
nous merci beaucoup merci avec plaisir
et on pourra retrouver prochainement
quelques nouveaux épisodes des aventures
des brocs des derniers épisodes tournés
avant à cette période de confinement
voilà c'est la fin de cette édition
spéciale merci de l'avoir suivi restez
chez vous et très belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]